wir müssen mit denen ja aus deutscher
Krise gehen die wir haben fühlen Sie
sich gut aufgehoben nee einer zwei
Sitzen mit am Tisch ja Entschuldigung
sie haben doch hier jetzt eingeladen die
äh schnellste Frau Hagedorn sitzt seit
20 Jahren führend im Haushaltsausschuss
die kann rechnen das ist eine
vernünftige Frau die ja ist doch nicht
wir leben doch wir erleben ja
Entschuldigung wenn wir heute eine
Infantilisierung der Politik erleben
wenn wir einen Wirtschaftsminister haben
der erklärt man geht nicht Pleite
sondern man hört drei Wochen auf zu
produzieren dann sage ich die Queen ist
auch nicht tot sondern sie hat nur für
ein paar Tage aufgehört zu atmen auf
diesem Niveau bewegt sich inzwischen
deutsche Politik das ist weder Kubicki
noch Hagedorn sondern das sind Leute die
Null Bildung und Ausbildung haben die
mit abgebrochenen Studien im Bundestag
sitzen und entscheiden Szene komplette
grünen das heißt
gott hat mir
entschuldigung das ist das Problem
dann sage ich Ihnen die Kamera ganz kurz
das ist ja eine sich selber auf den
Punkt gestellt Wiki hat jetzt die
Möglichkeit seine Grünen
koalitionsfreunde gegen Herrn Hahne zu
verteidigen bitte schön ja aber man muss
kein Abschluss nicht Studium haben um
vernünftig Politik machen zu können
in der Vergangenheit da sagte er selbst
eine Menge hohe Akademiker gehabt
der Grünen Spitze der Grünen Minister
und Ministerin überzeugt dass die die
richtigen sind uns durch diese Krise
durch das eine sehr interessante
Antworten sie mal
also jedenfalls gab es in der
Vergangenheit schon Leute die schlechter
gemacht haben als die beiden und ich
muss Robert habe nicht verteidigen er
hat gelegentlich eine Ausdrucksweise
aber doch nicht in den Ämtern Herr
Kubicki ich habe doch eben ganz klar
gesagt die Ampel hat das in meinen Augen
schwerste Erbe übernommen was es in der
deutschen der bundesdeutschen Geschichte
gab nämlich die 16 Jahre die vorher
waren haben alles verursacht was wir
heute vorfinden und jetzt finden wir
aber eine Regierung vor die das ganze
noch dilettantischer macht das verstehen
sich glaube ich nicht sie können
Entschuldigung sie haben doch eine
Galerie von Wirtschaftsministern
orthograf lambsdorf
sie sagen noch mehr und das hat ihr Buch
so eine Bestseller gemacht sie sagen die
Regierung hat den Draht zu den Menschen
woran machen Sie das fest das mache ich
fest indem wir eine schöne Rundfahrt
heute abend machen können durch Berlin
dann zeige ich Ihnen wo die
Spitzenpolitiker wohnen wo auch die
spitzenhaupt da müssen bis nach Potsdam
fahren nicht zur Frage doch erstmal
zum Beispiel die Regierung das heißt
Entschuldigung Kubicki und Frau Hagedorn
die geerdet sind in Norddeutschland
haben doch den Kontakt zur Bevölkerung
wer hat denn heute noch wenn sie mit
Blaulicht Kolonnen hier durch Berlin
fahren den Kontakt zur Bevölkerung ich
hätte ihn jetzt am liebsten den
Taxifahrer mitgebracht der mich hier
eben hergefahren hat ich habe die
Quittung dabei sie können ihn einladen
das war für mich wieder eine erhellende
Geschichte weil die Leute sind
verzweifelt weil wir von einer
Parallelgesellschaft
reagiert werden die die den Draht zum
Volk ganz verloren haben es ist eine
historisch das werden wir doch wohl alle
gemeinsam so sehen eine historisch
einmalig belastende Situation nur eine
kleine parallele als sie sich ich fand
sogar am Anfang durchaus in christlicher
Hinsicht nachvollziehbar in der
corona-frage sehr zu wollen übrigens
ähnlich wie Herr Kubicki ich sag mal
hier sitzen zwei wie sagt man so ein
freie Radikale das ist ja in einer harte
Attacke hätte man gehört
hier gewissermaßen die Demokratie
verloren wir sind am Ende des
Rechtsstaat so sinngemäß heute würden
wir uns alle zwei Jahre gerne
zurückbiegen weil wir plötzlich
realisieren diese Krise die corona-krise
die wir damals für die größte Krise seit
45 gehalten haben ist ein ich will nicht
sagen Nullung aber ist mit dem was wir
gegen vergleichen überhaupt nicht weg
vergleichen und das heißt wir müssen
wahnsinnig aufpassen wir müssen uns
bedauer eins das sage ich ganz ehrlich
wir haben nur diese Regierung ich sage
mal ganz ehrlich wir haben die Regierung
die das Volk verdient und das ist der
eigentlich ja das ist leider
deswegen ist auch die Haltung ich habe
sie nie gesehen
sie haben gerade wir sind alle Fragen
wir sind sogar alle beteiligt deswegen
nehme ich
am Ende so naja wir haben aber wir haben
aber ein Struktur ja haben sie recht da
dürfen wir einer so die haben einen
strukturelles Problem und das ist viel
gravierender wir haben erstens sehr
viele ich sag mal bewusst freie Radikale
die am Rand stehen das ist sie würden
sich heute Herr Hannes sag ich mal ganz
ehrlich als alter ZDF Mann so nicht mehr
einstellen weil es gibt doch bei Kubicki
nur Kubicki als Beispiel ist ein
wunderbarer Talkshowgast aber ich
bedauer ist dass z.B Kubicki auch in der
Art und Weise wie er bei den Leuten ist
nie ein Amt in einer Regierung
übernommen hat Kubicki hat sich immer
klar in Position gehalten wo es das kann
man gut finden das muss das ist ja
möglich aber es wäre mal vernünftig
gewesen dass die Leute die ja das egal
den hat er vielleicht manchmal zu dir
ausgesucht dann aber ist doch egal es
gibt Leute das ist ein Teil des Problem
dass wir zum Teil tatsächlich die ich
denke auch aber
heute nicht
in welcher Situation wir uns heute
befinden ich hätte mich äh 22 21 an das
entschieden definitiv dann hätten sie
mitre dann hätte ich jetzt wirklich
sagen damals aber das können sie doch
jetzt noch sagen also erst recht nach
der Wahl gestern Abend nehmen sie aufs
Handy in die Hand oder treffen sich mit
der Lindner heute Abend und sagen Sie
also ändern genau
weil sie hätte jetzt hier in einer
Stunde jetzt komme ich die strukturelle
Problematik wir sind in der größten
Krise der Republik wir haben aber eine
Koalition
bisher schön reinkommen
wir haben einen strukturelles Problem
das ist viel dramatischer wir haben in
der größten Krise drei Parteien drei
drei Parteien drei Parteien die bis zum
gestrigen Abend bekommen
bis zum gestrigen Abend eine FDP erlebt
haben die der Meinung war nach der
ziemlich niederschmetternden 14
Landtagswahl Niederlage sondern gleich
der Meinung war wir werden unseren Kurs
der Opposition in der Regierung noch
radikalisieren ich habe noch keine
Berliner Runde erlebt derart die gestern
Abend als der Generalsekretär der FDP
den beiden Koalitionspartnern regelrecht
den federhandschuhen geschmissen hat und
gesagt hat wir kommen hier nicht vor wir
werden dass der heute hat Christian
Lindner zum Glück das sage ich bewusst
erheblich Kreide gefressen weil wenn
diese Regierung jetzt nicht in der
hochproblematischen Dreierkonstellation
die da ist die gab es früher nicht das
ist das ist eine strukturelle
Problematik wenn sie nicht geschlossen
auftritt und das nächste Jahr nutzt wo
wir ja wirklich ein Jahr lang keine
richtigen Landtagswahl mehr
ihre politische Ausrichtung wir sind ja
völlig einer Meinung das Problem ist nur
das einige unserer Koalitionspartner
genau dieses Prinzip nicht beherrschen
ich höre immer wieder ich höre immer
wieder
schöne neue Forderung wir wollen mehr
Geld für die Bildung und die FDP muss
sie besorgen Christian Linda muss das
Geld besorgen wir brauchen ein neues
Sondervermögen zur Stützung der sozialen
Ungleichheit die FDP muss das Geld
besorgen wir brauchen 14 Milliarden Euro
für einen deutschen
Opfer die FDP muss das Geld ja nein so
so funktioniert das Spiel nicht dass sie
einen überfordern und sagen wir wären
wir wären die guten und aber sie tun
sich gerade leid aber wir sind doch
selbst Schuld an dem was niemand anders
als wir sind an den
Wahlergebnisse
aber nein ich muss es doch wieder
sprechen in der immer der lauteste sich
durchsetzen doch gar nicht laut
antwortet einmal Herrn Kubicki der ja
sich hier erstmal als opfergerät jetzt
sagt er dann doch ein bisschen selber
warum behandeln Sie warum behandeln Sie
die Partei von hankovic in der Koalition
so schlecht dass die da nur abstinkt
nein das tun wir gar nicht aber Fakt ist
natürlich wir haben ein
Koalitionsvertrag geschlossen im letzten
Jahr und ich fand das haben diese drei
sehr unterschiedlichen Fraktion absolut
gut Körper an den halten sie sich nicht
sagt er jetzt darf ich mal ausgehen so
wir haben ein Koalitionsvertrag gemacht
in atemberaubend schneller Zeit auch in
großer Solidität alle aufeinander
zugegangen der war getragen von dem
ansinnleben und leben lassen wir wollen
alle dass wir wollen nicht so tun als
würden wir alle vermischt werden nein
wir sind drei verschiedene Parteien alle
mit ihren eigenen Profilen und wir
wollen gemeinsam gut regieren so und das
was wir verabredet haben daran halten
wir uns auch daran halten wir uns auch
bis heute allerdings ist es so dass sich
die Welt seit dem 24 Februar absolut
geändert hat ich habe es ja vorhin schon
einmal kurz erwähnt wir sind jetzt auf
einmal die erste Regierung die Waffen in
Kriegsgebiete liefert das hat es wohl in
die gegebenen stand übrigens natürlich
auch nicht in unserem Koalitionsvertrag
da stand auch nicht drin wir machen 100
Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen aber gut
regieren tun sie immer aber wir haben es
gemacht und das ist doch eine Stärke und
keine Schwäche dieser Regierung einen
kleinen Augen moment mal aber das
bedeutet natürlich wissen Sie ich stehe
ja für die Schuldenbremse schon per
Steinbrück hat die Schuldenbremse
Einheit von ich habe sie selbst in die
Verfassung eingeführt da sind wir so
stehe ich drauf sie steht in unserem
Koalitionsvertrag es steht auch da drin
wir erhöhen keine Steuern das haben wir
alles miteinander vereinbart aber dann
kam der 24 februar und dann kam eine
Situation die uns vor so eklatante
Herausforderungen stellt dass man
richtig regieren muss
so viele Milliarden ich muss in die Hand
nehmen tun es ja auch das kommt aber das
ist unter den vereinbarten Bedingungen
einfach eine große Herausforderung da
muss man so ehrlich sein denn die
Verfassung wollen wir auch nicht brechen